well turning now to the coronavirus and
some good news
China is reporting a decrease in the
number of new cases for the third day in
a row but the death toll in the country
where the virus began is now nearing
3,000 in other developments Italy's
death toll has jumped by nearly 50
percent to 79 meanwhile Iraq Poland
Chile and Argentina have reported their
first cases of kovat 19 and Australia's
largest supermarket chain is rationing
sales of get this toilet paper after
panic buying hit stores in recent days
meanwhile criticism is growing of the US
government for failing to quickly
implement effective testing for the
pathogen knowing if a sick person is
infected with the virus is the first
step in determining who needs to be
quarantined our next report looks at the
testing method developed here in Berlin
and now being used across the world
determining whether or not someone has
the corona virus isn't as simple and
straightforward as it sounds the process
generally begins when a patient
complains of symptoms like fever or a
dry cough the challenge is
distinguishing a kovat 19 infection from
the flu or other respiratory conditions
because the symptoms are so similar
testing begins with a swab sample
usually taken from the mouth or nose
although experts believe mucus coughed
up directly from the lungs is a better
indicator many of the various tests use
a method known as the polymerase chain
reaction or PCR if it works like this if
a sample contains the corona virus the
chemicals in a test kit begin to react
with its unique genetic material and
start copying it over and over again the
copies are tagged with a dye
so even when low loads of virus are in a
sample they grow more and more
detectable with each new generation of
copies one such test for the corona
virus was developed in Berlin back in
January by dr. Christian Austin and his
team it can take several hours to get a
positive or a negative result
apps we'll look at our recipe order some
specific ingredients that they will
receive after like two days at the same
time order this molecule for us that
they will also receive within very short
time and then they can start testing in
the last few weeks the WH OS sent some
250 thousand of Boston's PCR ket's to
labs across the planet the means to
detect the virus quickly will play a
vital role in combating it effectively
but in parts of the world like Africa
the technology is still far from common
Derrick Williams was the author of that
piece he joins me now in studio from
more on corona virus testing I mean
first of all how big is the gap between
the demand for these tests and the
availability of these tests well that
depends very much on where you are at
China is has reported that they're now
producing and carrying out upwards of
one and a half million tests a day a day
sorry a week a week in a week in the
course of a week South Korea is that
would be the next country that's tested
the most number of people there over a
hundred thousand people that they tested
so far they've even set up they've set
up these drive-thru centers where you
can actually drive your car up and you
can get testing from you have tested
another car which is actually helps cut
down on the infection rate among the
people who were actually conducting the
tests Italy is upwards of 20,000 tests
right now but of course the other big
hot spot Iran we don't really have a lot
of numbers there about the the
implication would be that there's not a
lot of people getting tested there and
interestingly also in the US as as we
heard earlier in the show there's also
in the hundreds well let's talk about
the u.s. I mean what's going on there we
heard about this major scandal right now
involving testing for the corona virus
in the United States right it's it's
it's really the the Centers for Disease
Control seem to have really really
dropped the ball it really bungled this
pretty badly it's it has to do with the
way that it's set up the way that it's
set up in the States is that first the
the virus gets isolated by the CDC and
then the methods get developed by the
CDC and then they passed
along to commercial developers and and
they've never made it past that second
stage yet they've had to sort of jump
over at the FDA is not allowed to
approve testing that hasn't come from
the CDC and so so they couldn't use for
example this test from Berlin well they
possibly could but they'd but they
they're you the way that the the it's
it's set up in terms of the regulations
in the States the FDA has to approve it
they're now doing that the US has said
that by the end of next week there's
going to be about a million test kits
available and that they're going to be
testing people there's some skepticism
about that a lot of outrage in the
American media a lot of frustration one
if someone has caught the virus they've
recovered from it could attest then
later detect okay this is a person who
who had the virus at one point these
this is testing for an active infection
what you're talking about is a
serological tests so that's a blood test
the checks to see whether or not you
have produced the antibodies the
antibodies are these proteins produced
by the immune system whether you produce
the antibodies that fit with a corona
virus and so and that's something though
that is important information to have in
the long term for a number of different
reasons not least because we believe
that many people who have it have had
very mild symptoms or might even be
asymptomatic so being able to prove that
retrospectively that somebody is headed
or not headed is going to for example
allow us to define things like the
fatality rate in this disease but it's
also going to allow us to do things like
draw links between clusters of
infections that was somebody that might
have silently carried it from one to the
other not even knowing that they were
ill so knowledge is power the more
testing we can do the more numbers we
have the better but where do we go from
there how do we start to use that
information how do we continue to battle
the spread of the corona virus well it's
what's been very interesting for me
watching the discourse on this over the
last couple of months is that we've
moved away from it's the whole idea
spend containment containment
containment we need to do what we did
with SARS we need to shut it down at the
source as quickly as we possibly can and
then it just goes away but so the whu-oh
is continuing to say we need to contain
this disease but the only place that
it's actually that could arguably be
said to have contained the disease so
far is China and of course they've done
it with these draconian measures that
are not going to work in other parts of
the world and so you have there also if
the question is is how long is this
hiatus how long is it going to continue
could there be a second wave of
infections with people bringing it back
to China sometime in the near future and
so we've moved away in this discourse
away from the idea of containment
towards what's called mitigation which
is that experts are beginning to say I
think that we have to accept that this
is going to be endemic where do we go
from here in terms of preparations and
where do we move forward in the future
in terms of of planning for this Derrick
Williams with GW science thank you very
much with the economic damage caused by
the corona virus becoming increasingly
clear more and more companies are
calling for state aid some governments
have already responded with a variety of
measures South Korea for example is to
deliver an economic stimulus package to
the tune of 13.7 billion US dollars the
cashes mainly aimed at smaller
businesses like the country's numerous
market traders who have been badly
affected by the crisis the United States
states has altered its monetary policy
in an attempt to calm markets in a
surprise move the Federal Reserve
lowered the base rate by 0.5% keeping
interest rates between one and one point
two five percent China too has
implemented a range of measures to
support its economy small businesses
have been granted tax and Social
Security payment cuts as well as access
to cheap loans however the government
says there are no plans for a
comprehensive stimulus packages package
like the one delivered in 2008 let's go
straight our financial correspondent in
Frankfurt uh Lee Botts
is there for us only more more central
banks are moving to help with the
coronavirus crisis what are you hearing
from the ECB can we expect anything from
them yes we can president Christine
Lagarde said
that there would be appropriate and
targeted action commensurate with the
situation so the ECB will do something
we just don't know what and when next
week there is a policy meeting with all
the decision making members that that
are going to be present and that will be
a good time but it would be a good time
to present a solution if not until then
something is presented what we're
hearing is that it won't be a rate cut
the blending rate is already at zero for
banks and the deposit rate it's a
negative territory what we're hearing is
that the ECB is looking at injecting
cash into small and medium sized
companies that have gotten into trouble
over coronavirus having to pay salaries
having to pay supplier as landlords but
it sounds that sounds more like economic
policy than monetary policy more voices
are emerging is saying that these
measures are all premature and some are
even saying they're completely misguided
what's your take on that yeah that's my
take on that as well I'm hearing that a
lot from market participants traders
analysts I'd like to give you one voice
which I will read which I think pretty
well sums up there critics arguments
from Frank Dix Meyer from Allianz
largest insurer in Europe and he says
that the intervention of central banks
at this stage is useless even unhealthy
a demand shock must be addressed by the
fiscal policy in the countries a supply
shock is more complex but it's not a
rate cut that we'll be able to remedy
that would be bounced there in Frankfurt
thank you for this update the global
economy status amidst the corona virus
outbreak and oil demand is sharply down
prices are - OPEC experts will come
together in Vienna this week to discuss
production cuts the virus has been
paralyzing economic activity and
dragging on growth especially in China
for weeks their shops have been closed
and assembly lines have stopped air
transport is also badly affected in many
places thousands of flights have been
cancelled with no let-up in sight global
oil consumption highlights the problem
as production lines and supply chains
grind to a halt demand for crude has
fallen sharply that's had an immediate
effect on oil prices they've fallen by
21% since the start of the year they're
currently floundering at two-and-a-half
year lows that come as a shock to all
producing countries OPEC member
countries are now thinking about
throttling output again to try and boost
the price and keep their government's
revenues flowing with me in the studio
now is an ji o he's the CEO of Centurion
that's a company that advises OPEC
companies OPEC and all companies and say
how has Corona affected the oil market
thank you for having me Corona is really
effective or a market where there's been
a slow in demand and you really seen big
issue prices have gone down and let's
say you weigh somewhere around silver in
around 60 right now it's already around
50 and you really seen the market going
crazy with what is going on with the
coronavirus because there's very slow in
demand is throwing jet fuel demand and
so it's really really sending the market
into crisis right now a big chunk of
that slowdown in demand comes from China
is it is that the main driver China not
needing so much oil at the moment it's
one it's one of is one of many I mean
you have right now a lot of industrial
bases around India around Europe around
the United States that people cannot get
together you have a lot of people
staying home from from big gatherings so
you're going to see a big big a further
decline especially with jet fuel it's
really industrialization and
manufacturing plants so it's not just
China China is part of it
but it's going to be bigger and it's
correct now it's even bigger than China
and that's what it that's what calls for
a global concern on the coronavirus
especially with all prices on the oil
markets what can we expect from the
Vienna meeting tomorrow OPEC is always a
great place to be when with the
negotiations and the back-and-forth this
happens right now you have this big this
big tent with OPEC plus so it's going to
going to have to act a big question do
we go on a three to five
a thousand cut to really make sure that
you stabilize the market so that
consumers and producers can both live
with do you are you going to walk on the
supply glut that is what's going to
happen so you're going to see who wants
a car who dogs wanna cut by this big ten
with Russia included really gives a
chance that consumers can really feel
not continue to feel the pinch but also
producers can feel that you can
stabilize and grow the market so who
will be for production cut and and and
who will be against it and why it really
depends because you know right now you
already have a lot of production of your
market in hundred thousand barrels out
of Libya escalating sanctions against
Venezuela that's a lot of oil that's
already out of market so you just have
to be seen how Saudi Arabia which is one
of the biggest producers to get out with
Russia how they can how they can come
together I think there is right now a
growing dynamic where the Russians don't
really want to push for a cut but they
are going to have to in order to
stabilize the market and the Saudis are
always open to seem to have an order
discussion most African states are small
and so of the non-opec states would have
to also share in the pain to make sure
that the years we all stabilize the
market
thank you very much thank you so much
very interesting analysis Beijing's
decision to ban all group travel and
stop package tourists from leaving China
was hailed as a sensible step to contain
the coronavirus but it's hammered global
tourism many destinations are relying on
Chinese visitors these days and
especially local hotels and restaurants
restaurants who specialize in catering
for tourists from China are fighting to
survive a light mist partially shrouds
the fairytale castle of neuschwanstein
Bavaria's prime tourist attraction seems
peacefully aloof visitor numbers have
been tumbling steadily since the corona
virus outbreak neighboring towns
normally host 70,000 tourists a year
from china overall that's only about
five percent of the people who visit
this area but for those hotels
restaurants and shops which have
specialized in welcoming chinese
tour groups the virus has quickly become
a real problem it affects the Selective
it hits all the businesses hotels and
guesthouses which work closely with the
Chinese market with Chinese group tours
for instance they're feeling the loss of
revenue very very strongly and it can't
be compensated for it all in the short
term like this restaurant which targets
Chinese travel groups it's now closed
until further notice and this eatery and
hotel has also shut down for the time
being
companies tailor-made for Asian tourists
are located here and around the castle
they include a range of businesses with
pottery watches and jewelry made in
Germany made in Switzerland fast track
shopping tax free and with a direct
connection to Asian payment systems
tourists like these two seem to have
very little extra time on their hands
I'll cover several countries inside ten
days it's clear that sightseeing and
shopping are on their agenda when you
can combine them both in one location
and that's a major time gain on the
schedule and a huge advantage it's still
too early to estimate losses this 4 star
hotel has a broad customer base serving
tourists from all over the world less
than 15 percent come from China but the
increasing number of cases which are
appearing in other countries and the
mounting number of travel restrictions
could become a problem
had a few cancellations due to the virus
hasn't hit it too hard up to this point
and we're hoping it doesn't continue for
any length of time and at some point
things will stabilize and get back to
normal the high season is only around
the corner everyone here is hoping that
the situation will ease by then even if
that doesn't look likely right now